تطبيق تك توك الصيني على سكه الحظر عن
الاجهزه المملوكه للحكومه الامريكيه
والكونجرس يتحرك لحظر التطبيق في جميع
انحاء الولايات المتحده فقد اقر مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي مشروع قانون لمنع
الموظفين الفيدراليين الامريكيين من
استخدام تطبيق تيك توك على الاجهزه
المملوكه للحكومه قرار مجلس الشيوخ
ينتظروا ايقره مجلس النواب الامريكي قبل
ارساله الى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
للموافقه عليه الخطوه جاءت بعد دعم اعضاء
من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي تشريعا
لحظره في البلاد والسبب مخاوف امريكيه من
امكانيه استخدام التطبيق في التجسس على
الامريكيين صحيفه جورنال ذكرت ان مجلس
الشيوخ اقر مشروع قانون المماثل في
الكونغرس السابق لكنه لم يتحرك الى الامام
في مجلس النواب المتحدث باسم تيك توك
اعتبرت ان القرار مدفوع سياسييا ولا يعود
بالنفع على تعزيز الامن القومي للولايات
المتح ده الامريكيه